do you think you would be as effective
in Atlanta now had you not spent those
15 years in Los Angeles uh no I think
that pain
which is just your memories and feelings
that you attached to those memories
if you're able to conquer that
and let that go
you're able to to grow into a better
version of yourself so those struggles
of being in La those wins of being in LA
uh getting into those casting rooms
seeing the casting directors booking
jobs missing out on jobs in hindsight it
was such a A Life Lesson in school of
hey you want to make it in this industry
that's what you're going to go through
you're going to go through 10 no's to
get that yes you're going to go through
50 notes to get that yes yes yes and
then you're gonna go through another 60
notes to get a yes
it's so important because you're able to
adjust and calibrate your mental and
your mental is so important because
if you can be grateful for getting the
opportunity to say some words to
somebody that can say yes or no to you
and you change that perspective so the
perspective I used to have was I already
did commercials I already did movies uh
here's my pictures they know what I
sound like and look like they should
just hire me right that was my
perspective at the time and I felt like
I was too good like yeah they should
hire me like you know I can do this
but there's a thousand other people that
have done work more work than you look
just as attractive or whatever they're
looking for as you that's why they're
having you come in to read so when you
change that perspective from I'm too
good or maybe a negative like oh I
didn't book that but why her not me you
know and I used to feel that a lot like
why them not me
and you changed that too man I'm just so
grateful I am so thankful to just be
here I'm so thankful that you're giving
me your time to let me read for you or
you're giving me your time to see me
I'm so thankful that that person got it
because they were the best person for
that role at that time I'm so thankful
and then you change everything to being
thankful
the process is so much easier like now I
don't worry if someone says yes or no
I'm just thankful for the opportunity
I don't I'm not concerned with if I read
for 100 casting directors or I read for
one
I don't worry if someone likes my films
or they hate my film because I only can
control what I can control so when I
make something and I put it out into the
world that's for the world to judge and
whether you like it or hate it it
doesn't bother me if you like it I'm so
glad because then I made the film for
you if you don't like it it doesn't
bother me you still watched it to come
out with the conclusion that that you
don't like it but that negative opinion
on it doesn't affect me at all in the
least bit so when you think about is it
easier now in Atlanta or California it's
like
California needed to happen
because it taught me
what I had to do
in Atlanta if I wanted to make it in
this industry
you talked about earlier flying into La
I don't know if it was Burbank or LAX
LAX okay LAX so you said you kind of saw
like the hustle and bustle and how
everybody's rushing around and I think
that the attitude that you talked about
not to beat yourself up but of how come
them and not me I think that permeates
that's just part of what happens here
unfortunately that's the Dark Side of
human nature we all have it in US yeah
and so
I think it just you know Energy's
infectious we feel it and this is what
happens here yeah and I you know so the
funny thing is when I came to La at 18
and I flew in LAX when I took that first
breath and stepped out of the airport I
was like I am home this is it I loved it
I was like yes like like you could feel
the energy differently
now is a a veteran coming back it's like
oh man I I love it but I can't wait to
go home at the same time
um
foreign that thought of why then and not
me is very dangerous
and the reason why it's so dangerous
is because we as creators as human
beings as friends we have to take
responsibility for where we are in life
at any given moment
it's no one's fault it's not your mom's
fault it's not your Pat your past right
your past and all those pains are
literally just memories and feelings
that you associate to those memories
that is it the past is done so that
means every day you wake up you have the
opportunity to create a new version a
better version of yourself you also have
that same opportunity to create a worse
version of yourself
so that thought the reason why it's so
dangerous of why them and not me is
because if you took the responsibility
to say let me get better
let me just get better let me just read
more let me just go over scripts more
let me just kind of see what a landscape
is let me write more Let me let me get a
camera and just kind of practice
auditioning let me set up this lighting
let me give this line
you're already moving those muscles to
become better where
be happy that they got it because they
were in the same room as you so that
means that it's possible for you to get
in
and when you just start doing these
little minute changes and you put in the
effort and you take responsibility for
your life for your career for who you
are as a person you can blossom into
whatever flower you want to be
was there a book that you read or some
conversation with someone that helped
you kind of look at
taking responsibility for where you're
at
NLP treatment
Tony Robbins
as far as taking responsibility
that would come from my wife
my wife has given me so many lessons and
I'm so thankful for it
um
so my wife is 10 years older than I am
and it's a fantastic dynamic because I'm
the creative and she's the one that dots
the eyes and T's right I couldn't have
done any of this without my wife but
she's the one that holds me
to realism right if I complain you know
oh why isn't this film doing this good
or why is this person you know
she was like well get better do better
right right better do more what are you
complaining about complaining doesn't do
anything and then my rebuttal is I'm
just letting go of steam right I'm just
letting go of steam but
there's been no book
that's that I can say has changed my
life
there I'm not a heavy reader
um
I watched channels like this while I'm
making films right there's so much
information for filmmakers that if you
come across this video go to the library
of film courage and and you'll find
whatever it is that you're looking for
that can help change your life this
field that we're in
if you can find someone to hold you
accountable
and to
throw those excuses right in your face
and tell you that you're making excuses
like the way my wife does to me
you'll LeapFrog who you were and I know
your wife she's kind of self-made as
well yeah so my wife is from Puerto Rico
um
and she was in the I.T field for like 20
years and that's why she knew to have me
go into I.T uh and then she started uh
I'm gonna say she even though it's it's
a Unity but in reality it's really she
runs it uh a med spa in Georgia and then
we created a reality show for The Med
Spa very cool yeah and you can see that
um so yeah so that we actually did
independent distribution through film
Hub we created uh three episodes so
three 20-minute episodes uh for the spa
and uh
it's in Roswell it's called Park Ave
cosmetic Center and we went through film
Hub and the reason why we went through
film Hub is because this is a local show
right a local space we're able to do all
of the advertisements for it locally so
it's not an international thing where
it's like hey let's try and procure a
distributor even though there's a bunch
of horror stories with distribution but
the truth is they have certain channels
that you as a filmmaker just don't have
access to so I said hey you know let's
go through film Hub because we'll have
control over it 100 and then we can do
all of the marketing locally ourself
so it's past quality control
um and then now it'll probably be up on
Amazon Prime and like to be here soon
okay so we're just waiting on that yep